[Musique]
la sonnerie qui marque la sortie des
cours
c'est à présent celle du portail
gelabale portable qui si la personne et
de la voir sinon c'est pas dans le
courant tu peux rien faire quand tu es
dépendance comme la drogue je vais
prendre un seul accroc jusque dans les
cours malgré l'interdiction des profs
ouais ça m'arrive donc des cours
moins important par exemple pour moi les
langues parce que j'aime bien ce genre
de poids mais j'ai vite le portable une
drogue en vente libre et les opérateurs
en profitent
les assauts publicitaires sont de plus
en plus agressif derniers modèles au
meilleur prix tarif sur les textos et
forfaits sur mesure
de quoi séduire aussi les parents seuls
habilités à contracter l'abonnement d'un
mineur il faut donc qu'il soit complice
j'avais une paire qui avait noué avec
son deux enfants de 6 et 8 heures au
téléphone pour les parents difficile de
résister à la pression des enfants
d'autant plus que ce téléphone peut se
transformer en cordon ombilical qui
rassure moi c'est qu'ils sont sur leur
portable qu'ils sont vivants qu'ils nous
balles qui sont pas agresser bon c'est
vrai que moi j'ai mon fils qui a subi
deux agressions donc moi ça a déclenché
c'était vraiment le déclenchement à la
base le prix de sa tranquillité 40 euros
par mois pour chacun de ses deux enfants
ça coûte cher qui paye mes parents des
parents qui paient pour être rassurés
mais ce téléphone fil à la patte
j'aime souvent ces deux adolescents en
quête d'indépendance et part en garde
quand même un prise sur nous ce qu'ils
peuvent nous joindre par tous donc on
n'est pas obligé de répondre donc mais
parfois il est des rendez vous à ne pas
manquer avec les parents comme le repas
des parents qui se prennent aussi au jeu
du portable il est vrai que je me savais
quelques fins pour éviter de monter
jusqu'au deuxième étage de 200 cas du
téléphone portable
on va dire de descendre
mais existe-t-il une minute quand les
jeunes entrent de plus en plus tôt dans
l'univers virtuel et ses dérivés
d'ailleurs ils savent tout faire en même
temps tuer les méchants et répondre au
téléphone un téléphone devenu pour eux
d'une banalité
[Musique]